Donald Trump has suffered a major loss
and we've taken one giant step towards
seeing Donald Trump's tax returns and
Donald Trump is furious and he has
ordered he has been ordered to turn over
eight years of his and his company's tax
returns and I'll explain the entire
trajectory to you I've told you before
the Manhattan district attorney is
investigating Donald Trump's company for
criminality and requested a bunch of
personal and corporate tax returns Trump
immediately sued to stop the release of
those taxes a federal judge has now
dismissed the lawsuit meaning that
unless Donald Trump can come up with
some new reason to block the release of
those returns the Manhattan da he is
going to have to provide them or will he
right because what I mean is the
consequences for Trump so far for just
not doing what he's told when it comes
to providing documents have been zero
but it is a step a step in the right
direction
the argument that Donald Trump made to
prevent the release of these tax returns
was that as president he is immune not
just from criminal prosecution which of
course he believes but that's a broader
question but that he is immune also from
even being criminally investigated
period now judge Victor Marrero Oh
Hispanic guy Trump might lose it anyway
judge victor Marrero says that that's
not going to fly
rejected the argument all together and
says Trump's got to provide the tax
returns and in the immediate hours that
followed Donald Trump's lawyers appealed
it and the US Circuit Court has granted
Donald Trump a stay saying ok if you're
appealing it we will delay forcing Trump
to provide those tax returns but this is
now one bullet that's been fired by
Trump and the bullet has missed Trump of
course furious blaming radical left
Democrats on Twitter saying quote the
radical left democrats capital r capital
l naturally have failed on all fronts so
now they are pushing local new york city
and state democrat prosecutors to go get
President Trump a thing like this has
never happened to any press
before not even close so what's going to
happen here I'm gonna give you like the
remote the realist assessment of what I
think is going to go down
I believe that Donald Trump will use
every single option that he can he will
exhaust every crazy notion to avoid
having to provide these tax returns and
meanwhile he will further the witch-hunt
narrative like he did on Russia like
he's doing on Ukraine there's a good
chance it's not a hundred percent but
there's a good chance that at some point
a judge will say listen legally you've
got to provide your tax returns to
investigators they will then put out
just like the bar letter just like the
truncated memo about the Ukraine phone
call they will put out some completely
edited tax returns that he will claim
are complete records and then
investigators and Democrats will
correctly say no but this is BS these
are completely incomplete and then Trump
will say look I finally give them to you
and you still don't like them and before
you know it it'll be the 2020 election
and Donald Trump will win reelection
that that's a combination of realistic
and sort of cynical assessment which I
do happen to think is actually the most
likely assessment of what's going to go
on here and in the end we will get back
to what is in Trump's taxes that he is
so desperately and for so many years
fought tooth and nail to prevent their
release and the answer is several things
speculation but if we wonder given what
we know about Trump given what we know
about Trump's ego given what we know
about Trump's shady business connections
to use a very light term that is
probably too understated we could learn
from Trump's taxes that he is not nearly
as wealthy as he claims we could learn
from Trump's taxes I mean it's almost
guaranteed that he inflates the values
of assets to get loans and that those
assets actually aren't worth that much
and on the taxes he may even understate
the values of those assets we may learn
the names of the shell companies and all
sorts of forensic accounting leads for
more
to look into we could learn about
various types of fraud because what is
on Trump's taxes may not be in line with
other financial disclosures and loan
applications and things that Donald
Trump has previously disclosed there are
many possibilities here but let me say
this because apparently this is totally
legal and totally cool to say now
Kurdish hackers if you're listening
Icelandic hackers whoever if you're
listening if you were to find Donald
Trump's taxes
I believe the media would greatly reward
you Trump said it about Hillary's emails
to Russia can't be anything wrong with
me saying it to Kurdish hackers and
Icelandic hackers about Donald Trump's
taxes just saying I'm guessing the media
would greatly reward you